hey baby
[Music]
John nice to see you and welcome to the
show well thanks for having me I'm
excited
so I thought I would give a few caveats
for people listening number one I'm
going to operate on the assumption that
most people have very little context on
your life story so I will be asking a
lot of very basic questions and I extend
my apologies to you and the hardcore
Gamers out there but I think that'll be
helpful for folks and some very very
long-term listeners May recognize your
name because it came up
in conversation with Alexis Ohanian who
is a friend of mine co-founder of Reddit
who credits your story with helping
inspire the creation of that company and
of course your story
and the products of your imagination and
hard work have also inspired many many
others so the creation of oculus VR and
the cultural sort of touchstones and the
influence of Pop Culture over decades is
really remarkable so in the process of
doing my homework and due diligence for
this conversation the expansive nature
of the impact is pretty mind-boggling
but I want to start in the beginning
and by beginning I mean childhood
because I'd like to provide some
connective tissue that then leads into
later questions could you please just
describe where you grew up and what your
childhood looked like
yeah
so I grew up in Tucson Arizona
I was born in 67. so I did a lot of my
early early years in the late 60s and
early 70s
I grew up right next to the Yaki
reservation and
my family's on my dad's side has you
know Aztec and Yaki heritage
and but
we call ourselves Mexicans
and Mexican food was the food that we
all ate we lived in a pretty core place
was
really I only lived in that area until
about fourth grade but it was pretty
culturally significant to me because I
really learned all of my Mexican a lot
of my Mexican side at that time
and then we moved
my dad
went to the grocery store never came
back and so my mom got a divorce
and then met a met a a guy that was a
military guy and got married and then we
moved to Northern California which was
very very different than the desert in
Tucson Arizona
I would
love to hear you expand a little bit on
your time in Tucson and
and your experience with your biological
father because
I think it paints perhaps a picture I
don't know how many generations ago that
is but like in in human Generations it
was a long time ago and people
definitely acted differently back then
and I guess in the in the family and in
just socially
the circles that my dad ran around in
drinking alcohol was like drinking water
it was I never saw him actually drink
water it was always beer so yeah and it
wasn't just him it was basically just
about everybody and you know people that
that drink usually will surround
themselves with other people that drink
because they they like doing the similar
things together
so so everybody that I saw always drank
and that always led to all kinds of
crazy stuff happening because when you
know when you've been drinking you're
going to be doing all kinds of random
stuff at this point I think it might be
helpful to provide a little bit of
context
related to the hardships that John
endured and overcame in his childhood
because I think it informs who he is and
speaks to a toughness and resilience
that is worth underscoring so what I'm
going to read is an excerpt from a very
good piece in the Washington Post titled
why revered developers John and Brenda
Romero started a game studio in Ireland
and here is that excerpt John grew up in
Tucson Arizona his biological father was
an alcoholic quote at that point in time
John would have had burn marks on his
arms would have seen his mother getting
beaten up end quote Brenda said Brenda
is his wife money and food were tight
John's father Rob stores at gunpoint on
multiple occasions to get diapers one
day when John and his younger brother
Ralph made a mess in the kitchen his
mother stressed told John's father to
quote get rid of them it wasn't meant to
be literal
he just put us in the truck and drove us
out into the middle of the desert and
told us to get out and then took off
John said he was six Ralph was four John
recognized where they were and decided
to follow the truck spending a half hour
in the desert until his mother made his
father bring them home so this is one of
quite a number of examples but I think
it is worth including here is simply
because it is part of the context that
makes John who he is and with that back
to the interview it seems like when your
mom met
this military man that it was a real
significant chapter shift and shift of
environment of experience and I'm
not sure how far ahead we'd be skipping
but could you explain what aggressor
Squadron was
and how you became
involved with that
the aggressor Squadron was one of the
divisions on the military base that he
was stationed at in 1983.
that was
a place where the pilots
this is a cold war by the way
the pilots are learning Russian flight
Maneuvers combat Maneuvers and the
aggressive Squadron is where they all
learned
all of the flights ringing I guess that
they needed
in case they got in contact with
Russians and the point was not to ever
get in contact because this space was
primarily a reconnaissance space where
they were
flying u2s and tr1s from to do
reconnaissance over Russia to try and
find out what they're doing but in case
something happened they would know what
to do so
they flew a lot of other planes out of
there
I think F5 is a lot of F5s when I
started school halfway through night the
beginning of 1983 but was halfway
through the school year of my sophomore
year in school
I could actually choose to take
computers programming which is pretty
great in the in the 80s
so because it was halfway through the
years the teacher had to kind of approve
that it was okay for me to join because
I was halfway through learning basic but
I already knew basic I was finished with
basic and I was sorting Assembly
Language and when I talked to the
teacher and showed her that yeah I knew
assembly and that's what I'm coding and
I know everything about this machine and
all that so she was she was really
impressed the first day that I got into
school
and the second day when I came to school
she told everyone in this in the class
like what what to work on and then she
told me to to follow her and we went to
her car and she drove me to the
aggressive Squadron on base
and introduced me to Captain Spencer
and he was like Top Gun dude he was a
total rocket jockey guy he he flew he
flew he ejected out over the
Mediterranean this guy's done so much
stuff
anyway he
he went to a phone and he said a bunch
of different you know code words into
the phone and then this giant bank vault
looking
door opened big round one you know it
opened and we went inside of the inside
of this Vault a bank vault looking thing
it was in the middle of the aggressive
Squadron where they keep classified
stuff and they had already put away the
stuff because they knew that he was
bringing someone in that didn't have
clearance
and he took me to the back and I saw
this mini computer it was a crememco and
he said you know here's our mini
computer I'm just wondering if you knew
how to program it and so I got on it and
I noticed that it was using the the CPM
operating system and that you could
program it in in basic so I said yeah
yeah I know CPM and I know basic so he's
like you got yourself a job you know so
so basically I I got a job the second
day I got to school just because of
connections you know my teacher saw that
I knew how to code and then she ran into
this guy
later that day and told him about me and
he's like bring him on over
so it was just really really random
how did you get your very first taste of
computers when did you get bitten by the
bug
given the the sort of humble beginnings
where one would assume especially at
that time that it would be very hard
perhaps to come across or get access to
computers
getting access to computers in the 70s
was basically not going to ever happen
in someone's house like computers
weren't even in the home yet the
personal computer Revolution was just
barely beginning so only thousands of
people in the United States may have had
a computer and they most likely built it
themselves
so computers were very early they
weren't really in houses yet but in 1979
my friend I was addicted to arcades I
played arcade games all the time or
pinball or anything because it was so
much fun and so different but it cost
money and it's hard for a kid you know
who's 11 or 10 or 11 to actually have
the money to spend on arcades
but my friend came to my house and said
I just found a way for us to play games
that doesn't cost any money and I'm like
oh my God I jumped on my bike and I
followed him and about a half an hour
later we pedal up to the Sierra College
computer lab it says summertime in 1979
so I'm I'm 11 years old and I just
follow him and we go into this computer
lab that's really nice and cold and we
basically he shows me this computer in
the computer is a main it's a it's a
Mainframe in a room there's a room
that's just got a giant computer in it
and there's these terminals these black
and white TV screens with with keyboards
connected to them
and I mean there's like one unit
and and so he starts showing me these
really early text games
and these text games are hunt the wumpus
you know Star Trek poison cookie and
he's just really early early games
and I was just like really impressed
because I didn't need to pump in
quarters and I could take my time with
every move I could just like think about
it and then move
that was very very different so I played
for a little while I noticed that there
were only probably two students in the
room and I said well what are they doing
on the computer because it doesn't look
like they're playing he goes oh no
they're they're programming I'm like
what is that he said well that's that's
actually what you do to make these games
you have to learn how to tell the
computer you know how to how to put
stuff on the screen and and what to do
how to think
and I'm like I want to do that so I just
went over and asked us one of the
students what what does that mean it's
like print print statement and and some
other stuff and he tells me what it is
and he's and I started asking some more
questions what is that what does if do
what does that mean you know and so he's
kind of explaining it and eventually
because I'm asking too many questions he
just gets me
the book for basic that's there and I
just take it over to the computer that I
was on
and I basically start learning how to
code
in with with nobody kicking me off the
computer I'm sitting there with a book
and I'm starting to teach myself how to
program like a really basic Adventure
like which goes from room to room
just with a text description on a high
level it's kind of crazy 11 year old
goes to Computer Lab at the college and
teaches himself how to code
yeah it's incredible
and I didn't didn't have a computer for
three years after that so in the
meantime I would go to any computer
store in my town or the next town and if
they had a computer there like Radio
Shack has a TRS-80 or something I would
sit down and I would find one of the
books that has programming in it and I
would just enter the code into the
computer and play around with it and
figure out like if it doesn't work
usually why it doesn't work and try to
fix it and then change it and that's
like really slow learning
but that was how I learned how to code
in my first introduction to computers
was at the college because I never saw
him anywhere else pedaling over and was
the the main
interest at that point I I would assume
the creation of games and I guess the
follow-on to that is was there something
about
programming that
sort of tickled your brain in a
particular way is there was there
something else sort of intrinsic to
programming that appealed to you beyond
the output which would be the games
so gaming was the only reason why I
wanted to start learning how to code
because
thinking about arcade games it was like
I have no idea how I would even make
that but looking at the games that I had
played on the on the Mainframe was like
I could probably do that because that's
just like really simple stuff on the
screen
so when I could get things up on the
screen quickly and they kind of looked
similar to what I was playing I was like
I am totally on the right track so I
know what I'm gonna you know this this
is gonna work the interest was only to
make games but one of the really
interesting things about programming
especially back then
was that the programming experience was
extremely immediate
on computers back then you could turn
the computer on and it was ready to code
right then there was no no programs to
run to code a computer it was ready
so the
iteration speed of learning was as fast
as it gets it's like I could type
something in and run it and either it's
going to bomb and tell me there's
something wrong or it's going to work
and I'm like I just learned something
new so that iterative that fast feedback
either of nature of programming was
really really conducive to keep my
interest in learning how to code and get
better at it and it was yeah it was it
was just like building on stuff like a
very very fast learning all the keywords
figuring out how to put them all
together to do certain things and then
it's like I'm not just solving problems
but I'm starting to architect what I
want to do and so
there's there's these phases of learning
where you start to understand that like
anything that you can think of you can
make it happen if you only you had the
right words and the right description to
like how do I put a thing on the screen
well that's with Prince how do I put it
over there on the screen and then it's
like there's some commands for saying
exactly how to get to that point on the
screen so when you start breaking down
all of these little problems and you
know how to solve every one of these
little problems you start to have a lot
of confidence that you can do what
you're hoping to do and that just makes
you want to keep on going so solving
problems really if you if you're a
person who likes to solve problems
programming is absolutely for you
because your job your whole life is
solving problems when you are a
beginning programmer you're climbing
these walls constantly to to get over
them and learn something and go do the
new thing
so I'm going to Leap Forward a bit and
then we're gonna go back and fill in
some of the gaps and I'm getting very
much in the deep end of my ignorance
pool so I'm gonna need you to lead lead
me through what I'm about to read but I
was talking to my brother last night who
codes is involved with
technology and he pointed me ultimately
to a rabbit hole that led me to a
paragraph This is going somewhere on
gamerant.com and I was hoping you could
explain what this means so John Romero
ended up making the biggest advancement
in gaming since the invention of the
video game itself he was the first
person to make a navigable maze appear
on a screen giving gaming a third
dimension of movement
so we were just talking about problem
solving and this this may require some
explanation on your part but could you
could you walk us through
the significance of that and how it came
to be
games have been around for long computer
games have been around since the 70s and
3D games have also been around since the
70s so there's some really primitive
games
but first person if they're talking
about first person which is where people
really start to get into 3D
there was really really early games in
this in the you know say in 1974
is where 3D games really start on
mainframe computers
Works rendering a hallway scene and
maybe a character on the screen in front
of you and when you move you don't move
smoothly you move by a chunk of the maze
right so it's really primitive movement
but it's like it's rendered in 3D and
not until we get to say Battle Zone in
doesn't become very smooth and
Battlezone is line drawn you know
pyramids and stuff in the back in the in
in the scene and say another tank you're
in a tank and there's another tank and
they're smoothly moving and coming
towards you and you're having to use
tank controls to aim and shoot at it and
everything's coming for you but it was a
smooth moving 3D but it was line drawn
so the advancements in 3D
eventually get to the point where you
have solid filled walls so it looks like
a color walls looking at certain colors
so when you turn it it's not like seen
through an invisible wall and then they
start getting Textures in the mid 80s
so if you play say Might and Magic
you'll see it
I think some Wizardry games also had it
and and that was in even Ultima you know
into the dungeons you'll see a rendered
3D view that has texture on it like
someone drew a wall like an actual
bricks or whatever
but it doesn't move smoothly it's moving
by chunks you know still on computers it
was a lot slower to get to that point of
smooth movement but when we started
doing 3D in 1991
we did do a filled wall you know solid
color walls but we could move through
that maze perfectly smooth and turn any
direction we want it to and see that
maze in fluid full High Speed 3D which
nobody had seen at that point
so our Focus was on trying to make that
happen the speed was the focus for us
getting 3D moving quickly became
at least at that point with that one
early game that was really important for
us it wasn't to do something really
amazing with the 3D but it was just to
get a 3D scene drawing at high speed so
you can turn around in one second you
can just do a spin that took a lot of
computer knowledge of the hardware of
the computer and also how to draw a
scene not using all of the 3D equations
that you normally would use to compute a
3D scene but using you know restricting
the way that you could move to reduce
the amount of computation that you
needed to do to turn the scene into a
scene that that is visually complex in
3D do that very quickly by not having to
worry about certain angles that you
would see or turn your head or you know
roll forward or whatever so it
restricted you to only one plane of of
turning where you're just rotating your
head around you can't look up and you
can't look down and you can't tilt your
head sideways so by reducing your motion
that way it reduce the kind of
computations that we needed to do so if
I'm hearing you correctly and I may not
just because of my limitations as a
Luddite or maybe maybe not a light but
more of a muggle in this capacity but it
seems like you applied positive
constraints a number of constraints so
that you could use
let's call it an elegant code to
dramatically improve the speed of the of
the player experience and I'd love for
you to explain two things for people
listening number one when you're saying
us who is us
and why do you think you guys were able
to create this breakthrough instead of
perhaps other teams or where other
people simply not looking at it the same
way you were in terms of optimizing for
Speed and using that as like the primary
driver behind the development
okay so us is
ID software which is the company that
that I co-founded in 1991 we started
1990 but we officially started the
company in 1991.
that's me and John Carmack Tom Hall and
Adrian Carmack Adrian and John are not
related and it was just us four that
founded this company
and in 1991 which is the first year that
we were officially in our own
office basically to make games
full-time all day long at our own
company which is a major achievement for
us because like everybody we have jobs
like we had day jobs and but we we had
created a game in our off time and it
did really well and allowed us to
basically start the company formally we
were doing side scrolling games at that
time using a technique that no one had
ever used before on a PC it hadn't been
discovered for nine years since the
introduction of the PC until John
Carmack
figured out how to get pixel smooth
scrolling horizontally on a PC and it
was in it and it looked like a Nintendo
can you give an example just for people
listening who may not know the
terminology I know it seems
self-explanatory but a side-scrolling
game what would be a well-known side
scrolling game so people can visualize
yeah Super Mario Brothers is a
side-scrolling game and there were
thousands of them throughout the 80s but
on a computer on a PC the PC came out in
August of 1981 on the PC no side
scrolling game could move a DOT at a
time horizontally it always moved by
eight pixels it just chunked across the
screen so it was very chunky and blocky
when it moved and that's because even
moving the whole screen itself took a
lot of time
but to move it by pixel would was kind
of unimaginable because there was no way
to control that at a high speed when
when John made the Breakthrough in 1990
to figure out how to do that horizontal
Movement Like a Nintendo like Super
Mario Brothers on a Nintendo
how to do that on the PC that was
basically the moment that its software
was born because it was like we are
doing this in our own company oh my God
no one has ever seen this before I'm
just blown away
and when we finally started the company
it was probably I think it was like half
a year after that that moment
when we started it in 1991
we made 13 games that year and we made
them at high speed we made you know a
game took us two months but we would
make two games at a time
so we were we were so busy
the first 3D game that we made was
called hovertank one and that was just
to get our feet wet in 3D because we
knew that 3D is really what what where
games are going eventually because at
that point there were very few 3D games
and they were very very slow
none of them
made a wall look like there were bricks
on it or rocks or whatever it was it was
always some kind of solid color or some
little pattern of dot to two different
colored dots to make it look like
another color that doesn't really exist
it's called dithering when you do that
but it wasn't really advanced so our
Focus was to make the screen appear like
other games except make it so we can
move through the level smoothly not in
chunks and to be able to turn in any
direction and do that at a very high
frame rate because no one had ever done
that before and that was a focus of
hovertank one and that that game was
made in two months that was John's big
breakthrough was just creating the
architecture of that engine and getting
the rendering for 3D going at that speed
13 games in one year
I know nothing about game development
but I imagine with a relatively small
crew that sounds like a lot of games
what do you think enabled you guys to do
that
that maybe was not present for other
people working on games who had much
lower output what what were the
ingredients or the approaches of the
principles
anything at all maybe just tolerance for
sleep deprivation I don't know what were
the ingredients that allowed you allowed
you guys to do that
so the way that we were that we could
achieve this game development at such
high speed back then was that when we
got together is it software
we had already individually other than
Adrian who just learned how to put
pixels on a computer screen but he was a
fine artist on paper already for his
whole life
each one of us four
had 10 years of game development
experience like all the time
and
and so we'd already made dozens of games
each you know Tom Hall who was our
creative director he was a programmer an
Assembly Language programmer he made
tons of adventure games he did you know
action arcade games in Assembly Language
so he was already a very fluent
programmer John Carmack of course coded
since he was a kid I coded since I was
11. so we've been making games for 10
years and the amount of games that we'd
made was dozens each and when you make
that many games that quickly you learn
how to scope and scoping is basically
defining exactly what that game should
be and not adding to it you know
subtracting from it most likely if
you're going to try and get it done so
scoping is like this is the amount of
time that I have this is probably the
kind of game that we can make and how
big we can make it let's do that and as
you get closer and closer that deadline
you start cutting things away that you
don't need to hit that deadline so when
you when we did it before meeting each
other when we did it on our own time we
set ourselves our own goals for
finishing our own games and we got
really good at scoping so when we got
together and we saw what we could do
together we also scope together how big
those games should be and we had to
deliver within two months so we had to
know how good every one of us is how
fast we can all work and then scope a
game to that limitation and because we
had 10 years of Game Dev experience we
could just slam games out super fast
he would come up with ideas bam start
doing the graphics doing the animation
programming the engine doing making the
levels making the level editors to
create levels you name it all the tools
that are in the background that no one
sees to build the game data you know and
put it together in packages that the
game can access
there's so much technology that goes on
before you get to gameplay programming
but we were used to doing that already
for 10 years so
it was it was not just the experience
that we had but it was also the focus
that we had
we were just so happy to be able to make
games all day long as a job which which
is really just like the luckiest
position ever
so we could we could focus on doing that
we could we could scope our games down
really really well we knew what to cut
when it was time to start cutting stuff
if we get we're getting closer to our
deadline
and because there was no internet back
then
and no one had cell phones there was
complete and total focus because our
phone never rang it was a phone on the
wall and that thing never rang so
there's no interruptions nobody's coming
to the house and knocking on the door
and stop and interrupting our thoughts
so we could just focus for 12 hours a
day at least and just
code design you name it constantly
to build on the
emphasis you put on scoping which I
think is certainly
applicable to so many different projects
maybe all projects I mean that certainly
applies to book projects and and so on
that I've been involved with
podcasts right thematically choosing
where you go and what where you will not
go I was doing some research I read
a discussion of
different I suppose principles at
software and
a comment came up which was no
prototypes which was attributed to you
and talks about you guys being your own
best testing team and so on and I was
wondering if can't believe everything
you read on the internet of course but
if this is true if you could elaborate
on what you mean by that
so to get that many games done that fast
you can't be playing around with making
prototypes prototypes are like let's
test this and see if it works and let's
test that and see it
there's no testing it's like here's the
game that we're gonna make here are all
the characters that go in the game
here's how many levels we have here are
all the pieces of the levels that need
to be drawn here's all the animations
that need to be created
all the tools that need to be programmed
all that stuff there's no way to do any
prototyping if you're going to get done
in two months with four people
so we had no prototypes we knew how to
code already so there was like
because we can just see it in our minds
we can just visualize it we communicated
with each other just going okay it's
going to look like this on the screen
we're going to see mountains in the
background on the foreground we're gonna
have another plane and we're gonna have
trees there and we're going to have up
in the trees we're going to have these
characters and their AI is going to be
limited to blah blah blah blah and so we
just kind of describe what the game is
and we can do that within just like
let's say an hour we at the very very
beginning of a new game
in one hour we can describe that game
like extensively for what we're going to
create in the next two months and that's
that's basically how we you know we it
wasn't it wasn't like well then we have
to figure out this it was like there's
no figuring it out like we're just
making it
so there weren't prototypes it was just
we're making the game
later on with bigger games
that we could spend more time on we
could do r d but we still knew what we
were making so let me ask a
I'm sure a naive question but
if you are going to ensure that for
instance you can take an element like
that and remove it later if it is not
contributing to and reinforcing the soul
of the game do you need to think about
that sort of design spec in advance so
you don't
end up with a piece you want to remove
but that is sort of interdependent with
other elements in the game
in other words like the architecture how
you approach it need to be decided in
advance so that you have the capability
of removing something
in that way
when we're coming up with the design of
the game let's say in this case it's
Wolfenstein 3D
and we have the inspiration for
Wolfenstein 3D was a 1981 game called
Castle Wolfenstein and it had a lot of
really great
gameplay features in it that we wanted
to put in Wolfenstein 3D such as
when you shoot a guard you could drag
them and hide them around a wall you
could search their bodies you could go
up to storage chests and try and open
them and maybe shoot them open but that
makes noise might call guards
all these little little pieces of of
design that we wanted to replicate but
replicate it in 3D because Castle
Wolfenstein was just a top-down game
from 1981 it was in 3D it didn't move
the screen didn't move around it was
just like every other characters are
Marching around on the screen and then
and that's it like they might leave the
screen and disappear but your screen was
static like many games back in the 80s
so when we were making wolf design 3d we
start programming in the dead body
dragging and the searching and we
started doing that
we wrote you know that was the design so
we already designed that we're doing it
we already got the code in to do it and
we're now doing it we're playing the
game and we're going you know shooting
somebody going up and searching them and
as we're playing the game it feels like
that doesn't match now what this game
feels like because the original game it
was perfect it matched perfectly with
the way that you you moved around and
the feeling of the original game was
more of a stealth game so Castle
Wolfenstein was really the first stealth
game made
it was an action arcade game but it was
really primarily about stealthing around
and secretly getting out of this castle
and escaping it and we were doing that
in our game as well it was a it was a
recreation but when we got to the point
where we were doing some of the similar
actions that were not just running gun
we knew that is not what this game's
strength is the strength of this game is
doing this never-before-seen high-speed
rendering and high speed movement
through this Maze and no one had seen
that before in slowing you down and
making the player stop to do something
else was anti the focus of the game
right so the focus became like this is
the soul of the game the soul of this
game is high speed run and Gun anything
that stops you needs to come out so even
though we programmed in that stuff we
pulled it out because it wasn't true to
the new spirit of the game the one that
we were making it was like the original
games idea was transferred to our game
but all of the details of that those two
games are different the way that you
shoot enemies in in the original Castle
Wolfenstein was not the way that you do
it in our game our game is much more
fluid and simple and easy to control and
very very fast and so when we started
focusing our design on that part of it
we started removing everything that took
away from that speed and that's where
that you know but there were some things
that we had to leave in like to open the
door and wait for the door to open
that's actually suspense that we need in
the game if we didn't have any doorways
you're just running through a maze just
like blowing everything away constantly
non-stop but you have no suspense really
so those doors provided the suspense
that that was the original games
one of the original game's focuses was
the suspense of wondering if you've made
a noise and alerted the the guards to
come after you or if they heard you
trying to open a chest in the next room
and you can see them in the Next Room
and you're just like trying to open a
chest and you know if it makes a if you
shoot it then they're coming in the room
and they're gonna try and arrest you we
had a a new focus of our design and
that's why we start removing and
changing it so let me build on
Wolfenstein 3D and I have a question
from a friend of mine because I
mentioned to him that we were going to
be speaking his name is Alan Lee he's
the co-founder co-creator of exploding
kittens not just the single game but the
company that produces many many tabletop
games and card games
and he said holy crap amazing ask him
how the pressure of promising the world
a game when he didn't have one somehow
cajoled the cells of his body to do the
impossible and will one into existence
and we went back and forth a little bit
and he said let me know if you need any
links to early Romero development
stories that guy literally did the
impossible so could you expand on what
he means by promising the World the game
when he didn't have one and how that
cajoled the cells in your body I mean
that may not be the right wouldn't put
it but
to do the impossible just for people
that don't have any of that background
we made Wolfenstein 3D
for me personally that was my 87th game
that I'd made right after Wolfenstein 3D
we made Spear of Destiny that took us
two months that was number 88.
there was a game called Shadow Caster
that
views our technology
that we had made so all the tools that I
wrote
all the you know any gameplay code menu
code all the stuff we license our
technology and give it to another
company and then they make a game that's
game number 89 it's called Shadow caster
and then game number 90.
not that I even was counting back then
it was just like next game you know
we're gonna make the next game at the
time at the very end of 1992 after
making all of these games and really
when Wolfenstein came out everything
changed because now we have high speed
3D no one had ever seen this before
Ultima underworld was out and it was a
really great role-playing game set in 3D
for the 3D let you turn your head and
look up and down and all that stuff
which really slowed the game down so it
wasn't a high speed game you would you
would step slowly through a dungeon but
it was 3D it was like the 3D is now
happening at this point like you know if
it's not ours it's probably slow but it
is 3D because the world is now going to
become 3D right but it's hard it's hard
to get to that point our Focus was speed
that was where that's where where we
wanted to live with the next game
we had had such massive success with
Wolfenstein and Spear of Destiny that we
jumped basically to the front of the
industry with those games like
immediately bam we are we are now in the
lead
because nobody was making this and this
was the new thing like high-speed 3D is
the future were there first and we need
to keep our lead
planning for our next game after that
and then our planning was happening at
the end of 1992 was
the experimental the creation of the
engine that was a Wolfenstein plus
engine
uh after Spear of Destiny it led to
Shadow Caster but that engine's
architecture was too limiting for what
we had in mind for our next game so
that's why we licensed that technology
out and decided we're not using that 3D
engine architecture anymore and so at
that point we've made you know four
games in full 3d high speed all that
for our fifth game we needed a new
architecture and to to come up with a
list of all of the things that this new
game would do and we were thinking like
we need to go beyond anything we've ever
seen this next game and this was the
only time we ever did this the next game
needs to be the best game we could
imagine playing that there can't be a
better game in the world than this game
what would that game have
so we made a list a bullet point list of
all the things that this new game should
have obviously it needs to have it's it
needs to have like light and dark it has
to have light levels it needs to be like
spooky and these have bright areas which
we had no change we had no Lighting in
Wolfenstein it was just Fulbright the
lights were always on it was like we
need lighting control
we need height control we need to be
able to go up down up and down stairs we
need to have giant tall rooms really
cramped rooms we need walls to be drawn
at any angle which no game in history
had ever done at that point where you
can have a wall that's at an angle in
like a Wallace Jagged and all that every
game before this next game was basically
a maze game and when you look at a maze
from above it's just 90 degree wall
terms it's like it's like those classic
mazes labyrinths you know where you just
like drawing a line through the maze
that's what every single game from the
70s until that point looked like
Wolfenstein 3D was a high-speed maze
game
it was the same thing 90 degree Corners
all over the place so this next game
would break that barrier
so we're gonna have what we call
non-orthogonal walls that could create a
space that no one had seen before
we're going to make this game
multiplayer so people could play with
each other and against each other for
the first time because right then local
networks local area networks were just
barely like they were just barely
starting to sell network cards and the
cables and all that stuff and all the
the computer retail stores so we would
make a game that would take advantage of
a network if you ever had it and it
would take advantage of the modem to
play against or with your your friends
and then we would also make the game
open so people could change the game to
do whatever they wanted and make it
their own basically they could make
levels they could make new sounds new
graphics they could change the whole
game basically in mod it it's called
mods modification
so we would open it up to modders who
wanted to create a new experience using
the tech that we created
and we'd also give away the first piece
of this game for free into the world
and you don't have to pay for it you
just get it and if you like it you had
fun
if you want more then you buy it from us
that's called shareware
so we did all of these we we had this
whole list of everything we're gonna do
and we were very confident that we could
do it because we already know John was
already planning the architecture of the
engine he already was very confident in
how he was going to be able to do that
and at that point we were just on top of
the world like we had just conquered
everything with Wolfenstein 3D and with
the Spear of Destiny and so we're just
like Invincible feeling
so what we did was we took our two-week
vacation at the end of 1992 and we came
back in January of 93 right at the
beginning of the year and we're going to
start working on this new game that we
called Doom
and we decided for some reason that we
were going to put out a press release
and tell everybody what's going to be in
this game and it will be the best the
greatest game that that Earth has seen
he put a press release out before we
even start writing the game we put a
press release out saying this will be
the best game anyone has ever played on
a PC and this is what's going to be in
it and it's a breakthrough in game
technology and all this crazy stuff we
put a pressure release out saying that
so we needed to fulfill that and so we
started working on it okay crazy yeah
yeah it's nuts so there are for instance
as thought exercises some companies that
will write press releases in advance of
developing a product technology product
to help sort of hone their focus on
various elements right but that is for
internal use only you guys actually put
out the press release what was the
conversation around the press release
because it's a smart team
there was some thought I'm sure that
went into that decision what was the
logic if there was one behind putting
out the press release
I don't know why we would have thought
it doesn't make any sense but I think
that what happened is Wolfenstein 3D
came out like remember at this point we
were so used to making games extremely
fast with Wolfenstein that was the very
first game that we could make in any
amount of time that we wanted there was
no deadline on Wolfenstein we made the
shareware version of Wolfenstein in four
months and uploaded it so there was four
of us we mostly three of us
I don't know sorry those four of us
making Wolfenstein there was we we had
Kevin cloud in there for the very last
month to to add graphics and do a bunch
of other cool stuff we were very fast
and we didn't have a deadline on that
game and it released in May
the the shareware so we had the rest of
1992 just building up War this world
domination of like Wolfenstein there was
an internet top 100 list of games every
week and when wolferson was at the top
for the entire year after it came out it
was huge so we were on top of the world
but we were after we released Spear of
Destiny it came out I believe in
September of 1992.
and no one had heard anything from us in
three months
which back then with these accelerated
schedules and people wanting to know
what we're doing like we're finally now
doing interviews with places we're doing
radio interviews we have the local TV
station in our office
interviewing us and recording our
screens we have them interviewing our
Publishers like people wanted all kinds
of information about what we were doing
so I think at that time it was like
let's put out a press release telling
people what we're going to start working
on because everyone is asking is
constantly what we're doing next so
let's just do a press release and just
like it's equal information for everyone
it's not like there's an exclusive with
this one computer magazine computer
gaming world or something there was no
exclusive it was here everybody this is
what we're working on and now we have to
dive back down in the ocean and start
making it like don't don't bug us so I
think the press release is probably to
let everyone know what we're going to do
next
it's incredible all right I I want to
take a pause here just for a second to
ask you about
tell me if I'm pronouncing this
correctly
hyperthymesia am I getting that right
yeah okay
so could you just Define this for folks
and my question is also
to what extent this has been an asset
and to what extent this is had maybe a
shadow side or been detrimental in any
way
so if you could just explain what it is
and then hop into that
yeah hyperthymesia is like a memory
disorder where the the personal
hyperthymesia has a superior
autobiographical recall
and it ranges from
really good recall of
significant events and things have
happened in your life that most people
would forget over time
with hyperthymesia you never forget
those things they just don't go away and
a lot of people you wouldn't know it if
you're young but as you get older and
you start to lose Decades of memories
because you don't use them and they're
not significant anymore
hyperthymesia you don't lose them
they're always there
and the extreme end of hyperthymesia is
where you remember every second of your
life since you got hyperthymesia and
that could be
it could be born with but sometimes it
is an induced an induced memory Disorder
so
people have been hit in the head with a
baseball and boom they have
hyperthymesia and they have like they
record every second of their life which
gets to be
kind of insane because everything that
you've ever done is always present in
your brain and having all of these
thoughts like all of these memories
constantly is really
it's a big hindrance I guess in just
normal operation like just living my
hyperthymesia is
really I remember basically everything
that has happened to me mostly all the
significant all the significant stuff
and things that are connected to it
so like music and movies and programming
and games and that kind of stuff I would
remember basically all of that stuff
through all the years and I would you
know things that I cared about I would
remember those things I would remember
the names of people who wrote games when
those games were published the the year
that they were published all of that
stuff so I would remember everything
so it makes it a lot easier to just say
hey what happened in 1983 when you were
doing blah blah blah it's like well I
was actually programming this stuff but
I didn't have my computer yet so I had
to do it on paper in the kitchen and you
know insult it was a soybeacer
I could tell people what I did whenever
have you had that to the best of your
knowledge since birth or was that
induced
at some point I think I've had it mostly
since birth but got stronger when I
started to learn how to code at really
high speed after getting the computer in
the house
I was learning so much so fast I
actually had to take breaks from
learning because my head was just packed
full of stuff and it needed to settle
yeah
I had to like stop myself from learning
for a day or two before I could jump
back in and fill my head full of stuff
again
and due to the nature of what I was
learning in the early 80s which is
learning every bite of memory in an
entire computer because the back then it
wasn't like the knowledge of language
wasn't as important as the knowledge of
hardware at that time so I needed to
learn all of the hardware of the
computer that I was programming and then
the languages on top of that and then
start creating off of the top of that
information
so that was also a forcing function to
induce memory of everything basically
that was happening
I have a one family member who has
almost certainly I I never had heard
this term before but hyperthymesia he
can recall
just about every fact every experience
significant or trivial from his past so
he's much older than I am but can recall
the seating arrangement in every class
that he was ever in you know the
every word of every foreign language
he's ever studied Etc and what I've I've
seen is that that is a superpower on so
many levels but it also
as
an example has been challenging for him
because
negative experiences arguments
let's just say slights
kind of moral injuries all these things
are also as ever present for him and
it's very challenging and I'm wondering
if if you have seen any
I don't want to say trade-offs but
challenges related to having such an
enhanced memory besides what you've
mentioned
I'd say that's totally true for a lot of
people that have that for me a lot of it
is that the say negative slash hindrance
would be that
like I think a lot of things are similar
in importance even if they aren't so I
would think that this possibly
insignificant detail is more important
than anyone else would think and and the
reason why I think it is because the way
it's connected to other things it's like
if that didn't happen then these other
things wouldn't have happened as well
yeah
so yeah so it's like not knowing like
well say for this book what's what's
important what isn't important right it
was really important that I went to the
heavy metal concert
you know
so I could see that being has that been
challenging in group environments like
team environments where you're sort of
trying to weigh the relative
significance but because in your mind
some of these
elements that might not be deemed
important by other people are sort of
importance adjacent so you weigh them
more heavily has that been challenging
in team environments at all
not really because I think the most
helpful part of that is just knowing
what has been made before like what
games and game design techniques
programming techniques
approaches to certain control issues
like that stuff having that at any in in
luckily just having played so many games
over so long a time that has been really
helpful to be able to recall Solutions
or other approaches people have taken
that we don't need to research and
figure it out or figure it out again
like reinvent the wheel it's like this
game in 1984 did this
on an Atari 100 and we might be able to
do that on the PC or something like that
so it was more helpful to solving issues
or being able to make sure that we're
not replicating the failed designs of
the past
and that we were always
creating new things I hadn't seen before
which was really helpful but how
important or how much of a contributor
do you think to the the ongoing success
of the team was having two games and
therefore two options for things to work
on at any given point in time
I would say that having two games at a
time was not it did not impact really
anything because we knew what each of
the games was what we were doing on both
those games one of those games came out
a month before the other game right so
that was like the priority but what we
did was kind of we divided our time into
two roughly eight hour days or seven
hour days so we would go from ten to six
on one game and then six to two on the
next game so we were just all shift
because it was really important to be in
sync with each other when we needed to
like ask questions or whatever we were
all on a project and it wasn't like oh
you're just making a level for the other
game well I guess I can't ask you it was
like we're always in sync so we would
shift to the next game and start working
on that and then the next day we start
back on the other game and the reason
why we're doing eight hours and eight
hours or it's was Seven and Seven
was because we loved making games like
we we wanted to get these games done
we're learning a ton it was super fun
being together and making these games we
we'd be laughing
it would be new things that we're
inventing it was just like it was like
being in a lab where things are going
right all the time
so it was super fun and we could do
those hours without a problem and we did
it for a whole year
all of 1991 was spent with all the hours
that we were awake working on games two
games at a time at least and so it
didn't because we were in sync at the
same time when we shifted projects we
didn't get creative block with something
it's like ah I can't even figure out
what I'm gonna do with this level I'm
gonna just make a level for the other
game we would help each other if anyone
got stuck it's like ah you know I don't
know what I'm gonna do for this one
section and I'd like well put a meat
grinder in there or something and it's
like oh yeah good idea so we would we
would help each other but most of the
time we already knew what we're doing I
mean we kind of pre-thought everything
out before we started working on these
games and we could do it at really high
speed so we just executed because that
was that was the really important part
we got the ideas
and we have lots of experience it was
all about the execution of our ideas and
in sync and luckily because we had such
a small team of four people that could
happen very fast the bigger the team
gets the harder and longer it takes to
make One Vision come out the right way
but with four people
that have very distinct jobs to do and
they it works really really well
Doom
we we paused at the press release
you go on to create Doom
when did you after its release or maybe
in the course of developing it realize
holy this is a monster or it's
gonna be a monster this is gonna be
bigger than even our grandest
press release is could have predicted
was there a moment or an event a day
anything that comes to mind
several things happened during the
development that were that were
interesting in that in that respect we
knew at the very beginning of making the
game that it was going to be the
greatest game that we've ever played
because that was our focus of you know
like why we're making the game
so we already like knew it was going to
be awesome and the best game that we had
ever played so we didn't have we like
that was already like a given but while
we're making the game we got to a point
where
I Tom Hall left the team in August of
1993 and we brought in
Sandy Peterson to replace him doing
level design work and then I I basically
took over as the game designer of the
game that's that's how we started
stripping a lot of stuff out of the game
like lives and score and getting rid of
you know items that didn't matter
really streamlining the design
Sandy was making levels
and at this point the design language
for the level of creation was was
figured out because I needed to solve
that problem with like what are our
levels gonna look like that maximizes
the use of our technology that no one
has seen and creates spaces no one has
ever experienced before in a way that is
kind of drastic and not a little bit
better than Wolfenstein 3D it needed to
be drastically better than Wolfenstein
3D so that took some work to kind of
come up with this abstract level design
style when that happened and we started
to you know make stuff it's like okay
this is looking really great Sandy
Peterson immediately you know started
picking up that style because I like
would sit and talk to him at the very
beginning about like here's what is
important about using this technology
that makes us stand out and so he
started putting those elements in his
levels
and when I got to run Sandy's levels not
mine because I like when I make my own
levels I know everything that's in it so
I'm just like testing to make sure if it
looks good it's it's working well the
enemies are doing what I want them to do
the pacing is correct you know when
combat happens is when I want it to
happen when exploration happens I'm I'm
I you know have the area cleared for the
player to do that all of these things
but when I play Sandy's levels for the
first time I know nothing about it and I
remember the first time when I started
playing these levels I knew what people
were going to feel like finally right
right and it was like wow this is scary
you know going through this level and
I'm hearing these monsters moving around
I don't know where they're at but I
don't like that they're coming for me
somehow and it was great because I
finally got to kind of kind of feel
in a you know in a game design extra
game experience way what people would
feel when they're playing it now at that
point I'm so used to the technology that
it's like whatever even though it was
like it changed everything like no one
had seen a screen that looked this way
for us it was just like another day at
work whatever
so I was just focused on the experience
part of it
so that to me was really fun to to play
a level I didn't make and experience in
a little way what people were going to
feel like and then we got to a point
where it's like early October and I for
some reason look at that press release
again and look at the bullet points
because I was like as a producer type
person I need to make sure we're putting
everything in the game we didn't promise
stuff that we didn't deliver on and you
know we need to mostly get that that
bullet point list done and I saw that we
were missing multiplayer like we didn't
even think about it we thought about it
in January like
but we get to the point of the game
where like the game is mostly done now
and it's in this early October and I'm
like
whoa yeah there's no
there's no multiplayer it's like when I
tell John I'm like you will not believe
this
yeah there's no multiplayer remember
we're gonna do that and he's like oh
yeah so
it'd be John's a genius and so John
figured out
he kind of immediately in his brain was
just like oh I'll just solve it with the
peer-to-peer networking model
so he figured out what how he's going to
bolt multiplayer onto the game and make
it feel like it's been there the whole
time and just took him a few hours you
know he just needed to learn how to get
network packets going between computers
over our Network and then how to get the
game like what data does he send between
computers he's trying to minimize the
amount of data so it's fast
and he learned within just hours you
know the techniques that he needed to do
and it took a couple days to hammer out
some of the the speed issues but it was
pretty fast before I had seen him shoot
a character he had two computers going
and he's moving a character on one you
know in one screen the other one you see
the guy running around inside the level
it's like oh my God like we've never
seen this before in any game and and
then you shoot him and the guy dies and
it's like oh my God this is going to be
the most fun thing in the world and I go
back in my office and I get that code
running on my machine and we just start
shooting each other it's like this is
not oh my God and then I'm imagining the
level I'm currently working on and
seeing two people fighting in another
room from my viewpoint and I'm just like
there's nothing like this on earth like
oh my God this is changing everything so
I got so excited at that point so that
was another like holy this is gonna
be so different and blow everybody aways
and change everything
so multiplayer was was when I when I saw
that I mean this is October
and so that was really amazing and then
the lead up to like when we're about to
release the game
we're not online talking to anybody but
somehow the people knew were getting
close
we were starting to get random phone
calls at the office we have people
online
coming up with like there's like these
weird subcultures going on in Usenet
around doom and people creating games
based on like Doom being the best game
that could ever be made and and then
like them like creating a really crude
version of that and calling it Smashing
Pumpkins into small piles of future
debris and because that was such a funny
thing we put it as a cheat code in Doom
just there was a lot of internet
activity around the fact that we're
about to release the game and and we
never said anything so it was really
weird that the world was starting to go
nuts before we launched the game and
that was the third like okay but
up until that point every game that we
made we would put it out and then our
plan is to just wipe that game out with
the next one like the next game is going
to just destroy that thing so it's like
Boom games out next you know so we never
thought that Doom was going to be living
actively for 30 years like which is this
year it'll be 30 years old
stuff is being made for the game on a
daily basis all the time and one of the
greatest mods that has been created was
released not that long ago this year
like it incredible it's called my house
not wad hmm
it's people are still making insane
stuff for the game but we never thought
that was going to happen we just thought
we're gonna make a really great game and
the next game's gonna wipe it out you
know like that was it that was a goal
let's let's hop back to something that
you mentioned in passing that you left
in 1996 could you
tell the story of how that came to be
how you ended up leaving the company
we started making the last game that I
had worked on I did softwares named
quake and we started working on quake in
in 1995 as a team
John had already kind of started
planning the technology at the end of 94
when we were finishing Doom 2.
he was exploring the technology for the
next game which was going to be a
massive massive jump in technology
and and so when we started as a team in
1995 to make Quake there's a lot it was
it was like making Doom right it was
like here's this Giant mountain we got
to climb again
there's a lot of tools there's a lot of
foundational work that has to get done
and let's do it you know so so we just
started working on it and the design of
the game also was like you remember like
we started making quake and we couldn't
because the tech wasn't going to be
there but this now was going to be the
tech that we could use to make Quake
which is why we named it quake so it's
like we're going to do that game that
game was a medieval
3D adventure with combat right it wasn't
a first person shooter because that
never existed at that time right it was
it was going to be a 3D action medieval
we're going to recreate our DND
Adventures that we had and put it in
full 3d in a real full 3D game
so
that was the design you know as I'm
making the level editor and kind of
experimenting with 3D there's a lot of
other stuff going on at the company
because Doom changed the planet and then
Doom 2 again was even better than the
original Doom
it was crazy because we only had at the
time when we shipped Doom where it was
only six of us that shipped Doom
they're in on top of that we had three
other people in the company to handle
business
all of the managerial type stuff and all
of the technical support type stuff that
was that that was going to happen that's
incredible it's just so wild it was a
very small company and working on Quake
we had
we've gotten our team up to 10
eventually to make quake in in still
with the other
three people I think on top of on top of
that the company was 13 people when
Quake launched so we had like a very
small team and we had the world coming
at us and there was so much to deal with
Doom's impact and the Articles the Kent
guides the strategy guides the other
projects that we had going that it took
up a lot of time which wasn't bad
because at that time there's a lot of
Technology creation for Quake going on
and I was creating the level editor for
the level design team to start
experimenting with and it was really
just two other people on the team doing
level design in full 3d for the first
time and that was that was Sandy
Peterson and American McGee
so it was still pretty small we still
had more people eventually to hire onto
the team to get us to 10 by the time
Quake was shipped but at this time it
was probably seven of us it was pretty
small
during that time the design of that
medieval game just kept getting stronger
and stronger it was getting reinforced
with more things that could be done to
reinforce the feeling of that Medieval
World and do new things that we hadn't
seen a game do at that time in lots of
different ways so it was becoming a
really strong design really strong
really cool and
the problem was that there was we were
spending all of that year
kind of spinning our Wheels
doing 3D levels little pieces of levels
and stuff we didn't have a gameplay
programmer that could actually do
anything in the game because the engine
wasn't ready like we're waiting for that
engine to actually happen so we can
start using it John can I pause you for
one second just for people who
hear this word but may not understand
how it applies Within game development
could you just Define engine stuff yeah
simple and in simple terms what is a
what is an engine
so at this point in our game development
we had created this term called engine
and the engine is what drives the game
and that is the thing that puts the
images up on the screen it's the thing
that loads files saves files is the
thing that takes input in and makes
gameplay happen it's what makes sound
come out and music come out of the game
and so the core functionality
that is needed for a game to run without
any of the graphics and any of the
actual sound effects themselves the core
technology is called an engine because
you can put the data in and it will come
out it will play you put sound effects
in and then use gain gameplay code you
define when those will play and they
come out and so it's a it's an entire
set of code that any game can be made
from so it's called an engine and we
pioneered the idea of an engine in 1990
with our original Commander Keen game we
started calling it an engine even before
we launched schemes so we started that
idea in 1990 now we're talking about
1995 which we had made we'd made a lot
of games since then since 1990
20 something games so with Quake we're
creating a new engine one that can do
full 3d when that that has a completely
different look to it has more advanced
gameplay code
everything about it was different when
we got to November of that year the
engine was finally ready but the team
was burnt out because of the massive
effort that it took to create the
technology and the fact that they've
been making a lot of data that couldn't
be used because the engine changed so
much that what they made was too
primitive the engine could do more than
what they had created because every time
we were making stuff for the game
the engine would be at a certain point
of speed and we're modifying our levels
to make it go go you know run well at
that speed but that means it's a little
too primitive because the engine got
faster and faster and faster and by the
time we reached November we could render
much more interesting you know views in
in the world but we didn't build those
worlds yet and we were slowly inching
towards them so it was a lot of like wow
all the stuff I worked on can't really
use it you know so people were burned
out from that and the team did not feel
like they were up to the task of doing
research on a new style of game which is
what Quake was going to be it was not
going to be a first person shooter they
basically suggested that we should just
make a shooter because we know how to do
it we can nail it this is brand new tech
that's awesome already if we just do a
shooter we can all just like ship a game
and take a rest kind of thing
and I was just like no we need to do
this the whole world knows what this
game is it's in magazines like everybody
knows what Quake is and this is like
what I'm all about is we're pushing our
technology to limit let's push design to
the Limit too let's go beyond what we've
done before and make something new
people haven't seen
I wanted to make this 3D game experience
something no one had seen before that
goes beyond our first person shooter
you know our Forte it was our like
expertise was in Shooters and so how can
we go beyond the shooter and do
something that incorporates elements of
that that goes beyond it and so they
just really didn't want to do another
unknowable
Mountain they to climb like when is it
going to be defined you know like we
don't have a scope that that has an end
on it now like we we didn't either with
the engine so and we didn't change
course while we're doing it either which
is what really harmed the team
so I basically just kind of gave in and
said I will design a first person
shooter that will use all of this stuff
and what we've done to date
to the best that we can and then release
it as fast as we possibly can so we
started doing that in from the middle of
November we basically went into crunch
mode at that time even though everyone's
burned out they're mostly burned out
because they weren't making something
that they could see you know the what it
was going to be used for so
we because we wanted to get it done as
fast as possible we went into what's
called crunch mode which at that time
was seven days a week all the hours that
you can which is at least 10 a day
and we did that for seven months oh my
God seven days a week yeah and it was
really hard
you know after the game was released it
was you know like a month and a half
before I quit because there was still
some work for me to do to get the game
mastered and created to go into stores
and be shipped to customers that kind of
thing so I had I took a vacation I came
back I mastered all this stuff and I was
already planning for half a year to
leave because if we're not going to
commit ourselves to furthering design
it's just going to become a technology
company then I want to leave and go
create a design company and so I've
already planned after that big meeting
about a month later two months later I
already planned to leave and start
another company with Tom Hall and he
agreed that you know he would love to do
that so I said after shipping Quake then
we'll start doing that
so that's what happened after after
shipping I started getting in touch with
Publishers and and they also basically
decided that
I you know they didn't know John Carmack
mainly didn't want to work with me
anymore so they asked for my resignation
I was like well I'm going anyway so
let's you know sign it
it was a very tough game to get through
what was that experience of
separating from the company like for you
was it
challenging was it strange to be on your
own and to sort of leave behind
maybe the identity that you had built
with that team what was that experience
like just emotionally psychologically
for you
leaving and starting another company
was I was very excited about it
I was excited because I was going to be
doing this with Tom who's a really great
friend
amazing creative Force
someone's super fun to work with and we
both had tons and tons of experience so
I was really excited about that
but I really liked working with the
other people at it as well so it was
really like it sucked
but it was also exciting like at the
same time it was like that was a lot of
really great work there
but I'm also excited about what I can
possibly do
without limitations on what say design
could do
what we could do in design so it was
negatives and positives but I think that
it was mostly positive because we're
starting to do something new
and that was really really fun to to do
with Tom and we spent about half a year
building
relationships with different Publishers
to start ion storm and finally you know
after six months figure out who we're
gonna side with and signed up with idos
what led you to want to
write your Memoir Doom guy life of first
person what were the reasons for wanting
to
write this book publish this book
so several years ago I went
to do
a speaking engagement in Canada and
they basically had heard the story of
Doom's development and and kind of
already knew some of the stuff I talked
about so they said can you do something
different can you tell us
like your ER about your early life and
what made you the person that would make
Doom instead of talking about Doom talk
about how you became the person to make
Doom so I was like oh kind of like my
life in in early games so it's like all
right
I'll write that talk so I basically
wrote a talk that had a lot of the stuff
that happened in my early childhood all
of the exciting things that that had to
do with with drugs and and murders and
just the low income stuff today which
kind of shocked people they they had
never heard any of that before
hearing the audience and in the
questions later was just like people
saying you should put that in a book
like nobody knows about that information
I was like yeah I didn't really ever
talk about it before
and and yeah that would be a good idea
in fact
because I haven't seen anything out
there that really documents the ID
software's ludography really the like
what game started on what date when did
that game ship
what what's the authoritative
book on the development of all of its
software stuff I could actually put that
in this history as well so it was kind
of a two-fold
reason for writing the book was to get
the whole story out there from when I
was born until today
and to also be a really good great
Chronicle for
everything that happened during those
years and when those happen those things
happened and in a bunch of the cool
stories that people had heard before and
just put a lot of really good stuff in
there as well like
there was a game that I was
working on called black room and every
once in a while I get people asking so
what's up with black room and I always
tell them I can't talk about black room
well Locker Room's in this book so it's
really really people are going to get to
hear everything in that black room
is it true that Doom the name comes from
the color of money or is the origin
story a different origin story for the
name
yeah the name for Doom John it came from
John Carmack he was watching Tom
Cruise's The Color of Money movie and
when he was watching it and he saw
the the guy walk up to Tom Cruise as
he's got his
his cue stick inside of us a lot this
case on his lap and the guy's like
what's in there and Tom Cruise like
looks down at it and looks up the guy
goes it's Doom
it was like wow that's a really great
name
we haven't heard of a game called Doom
before so he he said how about Doom it
was like that is awesome yeah and that
was it the rest is history so John
people can find you on Twitter at Romero
on Instagram at the Romero
thank you for taking the time and is
there anything else you'd like to
mention any other asks or requests of
the audience anything at all that you'd
like to
mentioned before we before we bring this
to a close
well I mean I'm really grateful to have
had a really fun career making games
it's been a blast from the early days of
learning how to program a computer all
the way to today
using you know really advanced
technology to make shooters
you know with bigger teams I've seen
everything that's happened during during
that huge span of time and it's been
just a really really really great a
really great time overall so I'm just
really
just
happy to have had that kind of a life
and that's all that is basically in this
book John thank you so much for taking
the time and I am looking forward to
getting a copy of doomguy people will be
able to find out where books are sold
and we'll link to everything in the show
notes as per usual to all my fine
listeners at tim.log podcast and until
next time be just a little bit kinder to
yourself and to others and as always
thanks for tuning in thanks a lot thanks
Tim